During normal breast tissue development and maintenance, cells
grow and divide as they do in any
tissue. And as we learned about in lesson
six with many other cell divisions, mutations occur all
the time. Every time the DNA is copied
to go into new daughter cells, there's an opportunity
for new mutations to become introduced. Typically most
all of these mutations are repaired or fixed so
that the cells can go on performing their
normal functions. And providing structure and function to an
overall tissue in the breast. But if enough mutations
in critical genes go unrepaired, then there's a high
likelihood that cells will start growing out of control.
And form the beginning of a tumor that you
can see here. Now remember, mutations are going on
all the time. And so your body is really
constantly fighting a, a losing struggle in
some sense because mutations will keep happening. And
at some point, if your body isn't able to repair them all, one or two
or possibly more are going to disrupt normal
function. And likely lead to the initiation of
tumor formation. Now, obviously there are many important
proteins responsible for repairing mutations when they happen.
But two that are really relevant for breast
cancer are the genes called BRCA1 and BRCA2.
We might call them BRCA1 and BRCA2. Carol
has a mutation in BRCA2. Other women had mutations
in BRCA1. Either way, mutations in either of
these genes disrupt this process of mutation repair
and can lead to a much higher breast
cancer risk. Let's chat a bit more about BRCA1
which has been pretty well studied. The BRCA1
gene can be found on chromosome 17 in
the human genome and chromosome 17 has about
81 million base pairs. And BRCA1 can be
found about halfway down the link of the
chromosome. The gene itself has 23 axons spanning
80,000 base pairs of DNA. After transcription and
splicing, the resulting mRNA has 5,592 nucleotides of coding
region between the start and stop codons. This
results in a protein that has 1,863 amino
acids. Now there are multiple alleles of BRCA1
that are associated with the high risk of
early onset breast cancer. But one allele in
particular has an insertion of a cytosine at
position 5,382 of the coding region as shown
right here. Using the genetic code that we learned
about in lesson three, and that you can find about in the instructor's notes
on this page, I want you to determine the expected change in amino acid
sequence. And then select the type of mutation that you think this is best
categorized as. Again, if you have trouble
answering this, review mutations from lesson six.